hi everyone a good evening five days ago  we launched the elder scrolls online  Tamriel unlimited for the ps4 and xbox  one consoles for the first time in the  franchise's award-winning history  console players all over the world are  now able to experience an elder scrolls  game with friends we're pleased to see  millions of people online enjoying the  game whether it's by themselves with a  group or in massive battles we're sorry  we can't be with you in person tonight  but we need to be in the studio to  support the recent launch we're also  working hard on adding even more content  and new features to this already vast  world we're excited about what fans have  to look forward to next so here's a peek  at what the team at ZeniMax online  studios is bringing to Tamriel unlimited  this year  you